she takes the freedom of movement in the
EU literally Alex stannic a fine art
ratchet from Northern Ireland has run
the length of the Irish border 360
kilometers in seven days for me as an
artist and as a runner and as a young
person there's something to be said for
the fact that I can just I could do this
and over the course of a week I can go
on this crazy run you know it's some
kind of crazy travel but I'm free to
enter and exit different countries Alex
tannic is originally from Poland and has
been living in Northern Ireland since
she was 11 her aim is to highlight the
invisible border separating Northern
Ireland in the UK and the Republic of
Ireland her partner hopes that a return
of border checkpoints can be avoided
it's a something I think that's not
really felt in London a the tree
implication the way in which the border
runs means there's divisions halfway
through a road or through a field it's
not a traditional border in terms of
rivers and things like that it makes it
extremely difficult if a hard border was
to come into place on the run Alex has
been crossing the border numerous times
and without any difficulty it's a
completely open border and mostly
they're not even science that tell you
that you're crossing an actual border
from the Republic of Ireland over here
to Northern Ireland in the UK with her
performance Alec Stanek also hopes to
raise awareness about the uncertainty
felt by EU Nationals as a result of
Britain's votes to levy you I think if
the referendum didn't happen
I think some people would have just the
same attitudes they'd still see us as
second-class citizens now there's just
an allowance for that to be out in the
open and for me and my family that was I
think the biggest blow it definitely
took a blow for us feeling secure and
feeling like we're welcome Northern
Ireland voted against brexit with 56% of
the population in opposition Alex now
hopes that more people will follow her
footsteps and make their voices heard